it's getting late everyday we're told we  have all the time in the world  but the reality of it is we don't  at some point we have to make a decision  to write our own history at some point  we have to execute at some point we have  to make our next move  but for most people that next move never  happens you see we don't have time to  wait for our loved ones to apologize we  don't have time to ignore our addictions  [Music]  we don't have time to hold back our true  feelings  [Music]  we keep thinking we have all the time in  the world  [Music]  but it's getting late we think there  will always be another opportunity but  it's getting late our ego tells us we'll  have another chance but the reality is  it's gettin late our time is ticking  and we don't know when it'll run out now  is our time to make our next move  [Music]  [Music]  before it's too late  [Music]